welcome to canada i'm about to do a  piece with you for the launch of season  three of our talk too it's a very hard  show  i'm so excited and i love you you're so  so strong your programming i love you  guys  so we're going to be doing another piece  together but um  this season is kicking off  with an extra very bang i believe in my  card it airs  um my ex-boyfriend justin long comes on  for the premiere episode and  like it's just such a wonderful maryland  relationship  growing up when we're adults  [Music]  but we have lots of guests too  um  [Applause]  it's important and necessary  and it makes me so happy  um okay  break it off you know put the coins of  inspiration and ideas in it  break it on the floor every day